تحزن عائلة لاس فيجاس على
فقدان والدها هذا الصباح
مايكل فرايد ، البالغ من العمر 39 عامًا ، وجد نفسه مُنْبَبًا في وحدة العناية المركزة
حيث خسر
معركته مع كوفيد
يوم الخميس ، ولم يتم تلقيح مايكل
أحد النصوص النهائية التي أرسلها إلى
خطيبته ، قرأها
أنا  كان يجب أن تحصل على اللقاح اللعين الذي
ينضم إلينا الآن هو خطيبة مايكل
جيسيكا دوبريس جيسيكا ،
أنا آسف جدًا
لخسارتك ، تبدو خطيبتك وكأنها رجل ديناميكي
تصفه بأنه أكبر من الحياة ،
ما الذي
حدث ، هل ستسير بسرعة أعني
و  أنا آسف للغاية ، لقد
انتقلنا فقط من أننا اعتقدنا أنه كان مثل
حروق شمس شديدة إلى
حينها كان اختباره إيجابيًا لفيروس كوفيد ،
ثم في
تلك الليلة دخل بسبب الالتهاب الرئوي
ولم يتمكن من التنفس ثم
أصيب بالرئة المزدوجة  الالتهاب الرئوي ثم
كان الأمر كما لو أننا ننتقل
إلى مستشفيين مختلفين للحصول على المزيد من
الأكسجين وبعد ذلك أصبحوا على ما يرام ، لقد تم
إدخال أنبوب له ، ثم بدا الأمر
وكأنه حسنًا ، ثم اختفى الأمر للتو.
بسرعة كبيرة
وكان كلاكما في انتظار التطعيم ،
فلماذا أردنا فقط أن نشاهد ونرى نوعًا
ما ما كان يحدث مع كل
شيء وأنا أعلم أن هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص هناك مثل العلم موجود
بالفعل هناك نريده للتو  الانتظار لمدة
عام من بداية ظهوره عندما
أصبح متاحًا للناس مثل مجرد
المشاهدة
ومعرفة ردود أفعال الناس تجاهه ،
لم نكن نعتقد أن عامًا سيكون مهمًا
، من الصعب جدًا رؤية ذلك  رسالة نصية
منه أه عندما يكون في المستشفى
قائلاً أتمنى لو
تلقيت اللقاح اللعين الذي فعلته ، هي دقيقة تعرفها في اللحظة
التي ذهب فيها إلى المستشفى خرجت
وحصلت على اللقاح لماذا
حصلنا عليه بالفعل في اليوم الذي تم
تشخيصه فيه
عندما عاد إيجابيًا ،
لقد ذهبنا وأجرينا اختبارًا سلبيًا
، ونحن على ما يرام ،
سيكون في المنزل
معه ، لذا فقد
تحدثنا هنا كما لو أننا نحصل عليه أيضًا
لأنكم أبقوكم يا رفاق  بأمان قدر الإمكان
نظرًا لأنه جهاز الحفر  ht هنا ، لا توجد طريقة
للعزل مع عائلة
بحجمنا حتى تعرف ، أعني أنه
سيظل في المنزل ،
هل تعتقد أنه سيظل معك
مايكل لو تم تطعيمه ،
هل أعتقد أنه سيكون على الأقل
قلل من الأعراض وكان بإمكانه
القتال لفترة أطول ولديه فرصة أفضل